but as for most people we have a
mechanism that will allow us
that makes us extremely sensitive to the
small losses that you incur along the
way
in a way that may not be compensated
by the extreme win and
the story is similar on the other side
I'll come back to it yeah effectively
that's what this explanation is why you
went to Stockholm in 2002.
that's exactly prospect theory Danny
discovered the following
you'd rather make a million dollars over
a year in small amounts you get more
pleasure if you're going to make money
make it in small amounts and if you're
going to lose money or have a bad event
have it all at once
because losing you'd rather lose a
million dollar in one day than lose
a little bit of money
also even a smaller amounts okay over
two years because by the third day it's
like Chinese torture no and and that's
prospect theory that's the reason he had
the the Nobel he's the reason he you
know that's the whole thing and people
still haven't absorbed that point
the prospects here that's what what and
and when we met in 2003 I I immediately
found you know the embodiment of my idea
right there you know in in in in in
prospect theory in in that equation but
in a way what you are I mean
if we link it with prospects Theory what
you're prescribing goes against the
grain
you're prescribing a way of being or a
way of doing things that exposes an
individual to to a long series of small
losses
in the hope of a very large game it's
not not quite what I'm doing is the
opposite trying to tell people do not uh
mortgage your future for small gains now
and they get it when you present it that
way there's another psychological thing
that people tend to create a narrative
that you know the large event will never
happen
so and there's another dimension of why
do we have uh Bankers for example they
make pennies they make pennies make
pennies and when
a crisis happens they lose everything
they've made before and effectively in
1982 I was writing on the Black Swan I
got so many hate letters from Bankers in
1982 I showed why the banks lost in one
quarter more money that they made in the
history of banking until then history
Money Center banking
they repeated it in 1991 and of course
2007 you don't need more you know
examples so
and every time that there's another
dimension
it's not their money they're losing it's
your money anyone here who files that
piece of paper on April 15th
is subsidizing them because when they
make the money it's theirs
and when they lose the money
it's hours on April 15th taxpayer
sponsors it so we have here what I call
a transfer of anti-fragility
a banker is anti-fragile he has upside
no downside
taxpayer has downside no upside
so you're going to have a lot of risk
hiding on top of the psychological thing
so and then you told me you know there
is the two effect and I call them one
Fooled by Randomness
the other Crooks of randomness
okay so there's the fools of Randomness
and the Crux of Randomness you see it's
a combination that we see present in
society if you remove one the Crux of
randomness
you would have much less of it this of
course is phenomenal would prevail
although there's something called dread
risk people may be scared by extreme
events if you present it to them
properly
as you have shown but uh but the the
phenomenon Crux of Randomness is what we
definitely can remedy but I have one
more thing to say
A system that does not
convert stressors problems variability
into fuel is doomed well
I keep going back to the same point
this is not really what people want to
do yeah that is I certainly uh you know
many of us certainly
go almost directly in New York from
heating to air conditioning and vice
versa because we do like the constant
temperature
so it you are making a point which I
think is true and deep that
in in some situations uh that we are
made for variability that as we are
designed by evolution
uh to to be able to cope with stresses
and indeed as a point you made
absolutely correctly to benefit from
stresses
but we're also designed to avoid
stresses
to try to avoid stresses
identical to Randomness we're made to
hate randomness
because the environment was given us
Randomness and it prevented us from
dying prevented us from encountering the
big uh you know large-scale event so we
made to hate all kind of Randomness
because we're not you know fine-tuned
you know for for such uh subtlety okay
that some Randomness and small amounts
is good for us so we realize Randomness
is bad it's bad okay so it's the same
way the same way we think that stressors
are bad
when in fact bad big stressors are bad
small stresses are beneficial this is
the non-linearity that we don't capture
intellectually well the psychology of it
is the following that we're actually
relatively more sensitive to small
losses and to Big losses and to small
harms and to big homes that is this we
have a limited ability actually to feel
pain
and we feel a lot of pain for very
little harm and then it doesn't get
worse proportionately so that in some in
a very real sense we're designed against
what you want yeah but except that guess
what saved us from this religion
I mean I'm Greek Orthodox all right I'm
not practicing but sort of sometimes
practicing for dietary reasons okay we
have and we have I mean think about it
the religions force you to fast
force you to to have variability in your
food especially we have 40 Days for land
40 days plus every Wednesday and Friday
no and you're vegan so you're vegan so
many days why
to prevent you from having protein
because we're we're part lion part cow
the lion in us gets the protein
with with the with a random frequency
whereas the cow in US eats a salad
without dressing every day all the time
right so you see the boring and and the
the hunter so if you're made to get
protein episodically intermittently and
you get it all the time you may be
harmed religions have evolved to prevent
us from that by Banning it from eating
protein
seven days a week
you see so you can look at the fast and
Ramadan it has this very same purpose so
you see all these rituals were there to
help us cope
forces on grounds you know of course the
religion is like someone packaging the
story uh for a uh you know giving you a
story in fact to force you to do
something else
and that was I mean so we have had
mechanism to correct for this uh for the
diseases of abundance
I mean we live in a world today where a
lot more people are dying of over
nutrition than other nutrition
you see we have 700 million people
supposed to be under uh you know uh fed
but but of these the really ill very
small number well uh you
I want to change the subject yeah
another great uh mental models is doing
things
which have asymmetry and doing things
where uh downside is muted or
non-existent
and upside is unknown uh you know and in
fact if you look at a person like Jeff
Bezos or Amazon uh that's what they do
they basically throw a lot of stuff
against the wall uh they're all
relatively small bets most of them don't
work uh but a few do and then when they
do you get huge payoffs anytime you can
identify asymmetry uh in some action or
something that you could take uh you
should go for it so for example uh you
know Charlie Charlie told me and I've
seen it with him is he likes to
introduce Randomness into his life so
sometimes when I meet him you know from
his court pocket he'll remove a bunch of
letters he's received from people all
over the world you know there's a lot of
people write to him and whatever
and he'll go through a few letters and
say okay this one uh uh I'm gonna have
breakfast with this person
I'm just thinking you know that guy's
gonna fall off his chair and uh someone
from uh you know Charlie's assistant
contacts him or something uh but Charlie
likes likes that Randomness it has led
to uh many great friendships and in some
cases business Partnerships uh for him
and again there's no downside anyway uh
like I said I think that it's it's led
to so many things uh and I I think I
should do more I don't do enough
with asymmetry uh I think Amazon does an
awesome job with asymmetry uh I think
tencent does an awesome job in asymmetry
um I think Facebook does a terrible job
with asymmetry so the difference between
Amazon and Facebook even though you
didn't ask is you know uh
the two Jeffs throw a lot of stuff
against the wall and uh and basically
um basically more stuff doesn't work but
it's small bets and uh you know at meta
there's a massive multi-billion single
bet and uh good luck with that that kind
of violates the rules
reflections
[Music]
besides the Distortion insensitivity
caused by the magnitude level of the
gain or loss we can also notice another
important bias in the graph and that is
that for the same unit of loss or gain
we feel more the pain than the happiness
this bias is called loss aversion this
is one of the most important biases in
human nature and it explains a great
deal of our reactions this is why it is
said that 70 percent of all consumer
purchases are done to avoid a loss and
30 percent to get a positive benefit
according to ex-fbi negotiator and
business leader Chris Boss or to some
extent why people are afraid of
variability in general so afraid that in
the financial markets people often even
use volatility that is the fluctuation
of prices as a measure of risk which in
an objective sense doesn't make any
sense because real risk is only the
potential for permanent loss of capital
embracing Randomness having some
variability in the sense of adventure in
your life is also way more fun than
having a monotonous life in which you
already know what you are going to be
doing at each hour or minute of your day
this is what Nasim calls
touristification of your life just like
in a tour everything has a specific time
in the schedule your life becomes a tour
in itself if you already know in advance
what you will be doing at each moment of
your day also having everything timely
planned makes you more fragile because
an unexpected event can only be negative
that is there is only the downside
whereas if you are adventurous
unexpected events will definitely have
more upside than downside some aphorisms
from Nasim to live on this if you know
in the morning what your day looks like
with any position you are a little bit
dead the more Precision the more that
you are you have a calibrated life when
most of what you fear has a TT lighting
Prospect of Adventure the consistency
bias makes the prospect theory even more
powerful we think that the big and
frequent event positive or negative will
never happen so we do not seek the big
potential payoff or prepare ourselves
for a big potential loss and we get
complacent with a small frequent gains
to feel like we are doing well since it
maximizes pleasure and that we are in
the right path and everyone in our
Social Circle respects or accepts us not
only because you are often winning but
also because most people will choose
this path falling prey of the prospect
theory and consistency bias will make
you way more likely to find and stay in
a stable job rather than starting an
entrepreneurial banter if you're an
employee you have small frequent gains
that is your monthly salary you feel
good because you are feeling the
pleasure of the gain in many doses but
you also set the potential big event of
losing your job and even defaulting on
your mortgage if you get any maybe this
structure of having certain and frequent
gains is one motive for nasim's aphorism
the 3 three most harmful addictions are
heroin carbohydrates and a monthly
salary if you're an entrepreneur you're
bleeding a bit every day but you also
set yourself up to profit from a big or
frequent gain at some point in the
future and also because the upside
potential in the entrepreneurship is
unlimited you could make way more money
than the accumulated small gains of a
corporate job in terms of biased
feelings you feel bad every day and the
day you win big you don't feel it that
much because our sensitivity to feel
decreases so it sucks from a feelings
perspective but in absolute terms in
terms of Financial Freedom or freedom in
general I think you're way better off in
words of Navarro we can't if you're
willing to bleed a little bit every day
but in exchange you will win big later
you will do better that is by the way
entrepreneurship entrepreneurs bleed
every day they are not making money they
are losing money they are constantly
stressed out all the responsibility is
upon them but when they win they win big
on average they will make more would you
like to get access to the finest nuggets
from the best non-fiction books out
there if you do you should check out
short form for disclosure short form is
not sponsoring this video but there is
an affiliate Link in the video
description why am I promoting short
form well my purpose through this
channel is to collect valuable insights
from videos of people that I deeply
admire now imagine if you can easily get
the most valuable insights from the best
non-fiction books this is what you can
find on short form a curated selection
of the best books and for each book you
can find a carefully crafted summary in
which all the book's relevant ideas are
analyzed this is why I absolutely love
to read on short film and would
recommend it to anyone as Charlie Monger
argues to have a good unsuccessful life
you have to create a mental model from
all the big ideas from all the big
disciplines and short film can be
extremely helpful for this matter as it
literally extracts all the big ideas
from the best non-fiction books helping
you to create this mental model in a
faster and more efficient way and with
these valuable ideas becoming second
nature to us over time I think we will
be able to build our best lives by
standing on the shoulders of giants as
Seer Isaac Newton would put it now the
way I personally read on short form is
to pick from my personal Library any
book that sparks my interest at that
moment and start reading it typically I
will read sometimes in the morning after
waking up sometimes at night before
going to sleep and many times I will do
a short read on the mobile phone app
when for instance I'm in a restaurant
alone waiting for the food or commuting
somewhere I created my personal Library
by quickly scan through all the books on
short form and for any book to make it
on my library it has not only to
interest me but it also must fulfill at
least one of two conditions one is that
I already know the author of the book
from an interview in some podcast or any
other source that I personally trust and
the other is that the book itself has
been publicly recommended by people who
I deeply admire if you are interested in
short form you can visit my special link
shortfarm.com picking nuggets I will
also leave the link in the description
of the video by joining with my
affiliate link you will be supporting
this Channel and you can have unlimited
access for 5 days and a 20 discount on
the annual subscription if you do choose
to keep going after the end of your
trial thanks for watching
foreign